okay so Coq Dosa is a micro drill of the
keyhon Masa where you work on that
rotating cross energetic pattern okay
what we're going to do is a micro drill
of the micro drill so you're going to
use that same
uh energetic pattern
and you're going to do we could call it
a a hot rod deconstruction
so I'm gonna displace her hata okay
which is a part of all your kazushi so
right now normally when you do cocidosa
it kinda looks like you might have it I
can tell you don't though
but all I'm going to do now is uh the on
the scent on her Center
and you have to push to generate oh my
Tom's end field oh
oh
foreign
just take her Hot Off
so for the heart of the to be Hara it
has to be in a three element
relationship with the perimeters so her
head and her base
right there's no Center if I don't have
a perimeter of symmetrical on both sides
so what I'm doing is displacing that
part
okay
and therefore you deconstruct the
relationship okay that's true
okay so what you're
doing you use the right word and I think
that's probably the best uh uh English
word there's an Alchemy that's happening
there's a a transformation of one aspect
into something other than it was and
it's an internal Alchemy okay but you
can only work with these Universal
principles okay
okay so in essence
we in Aikido discourse have an Ike and a
Coq
but they are
um
concentric with of course yin and yang
but concentric with a let us say
Obviously a communion uh element and
then a separation element but you could
also think of it as a
uh uh a stabilizing element and a
disruptive element okay so for example
uh ikey is a stabilizing element and
cocues a disruptive elements so uh when
we do when you feel the eye cohesion we
are I am maintaining our relationship
and when you feel the Coq projections
that I'm done with ours have you seen
you want to think it that way and what
you're trying to do uh in your Arts is
use both of those as you need to you're
trying to bring agency
to these natural elements that are out
there okay so in this drill
um I never really uh
separate do you get that so I don't I
don't I'm not I'm not gonna
do the disruptive elements you see so
you're going to feel a lot more eye key
and I take Coq
uh never to that the absence of the ID I
take the disruptive Force never to the
cessation of the uh sustaining Force
okay so the first thing again you see
how you have a push in me
you are going to generate the tanden
field
from The Young point of view as you push
into me then we're regenerated so it's
not that I I go here and I try to do an
external
yin yang so some of you I can see that's
where you get into problems uh for
example if I get over here you can do an
external you see but you can't do the
micro micro drill of that we're doing
because you get stuck okay so I want you
to understand that he's he's generating
now the tandem field and he generated my
condemn field and now I play with those
two energies inside
and all I'm doing I'm not I don't really
pay attention to the arms
I pay attention to the to the the heaven
she and the Earth sheet in my body which
is synonymous with or
concentric with ice and Coq and I just
keep them uh floating I
foreign
[Music]
so why I'm telling that as I was
watching you
you were going over into the disruptive
element and you want to hang out
uh with these two Energies
merging
separating
merging separating do you see that okay
do you get that okay so
um
the art is called Aikido it's not called
kokudo you see that so while there is a
sense that I am integrating I can call Q
you see that
um and while I while I do know the
disrupted disruptive aspect uh I as
a human being
as an aikidoka I want to hang out more
in the sustainable element
and in the I.T okay
so and that's that's what you're doing
here so you you were here like that and
you see that's my little projection you
see that's kind of your balance is there
and you're like
[Music]
okay but in this micro drill I am uh
working
from more the I key point of view okay
so as as I'm in this relationship this
is where I'm at
okay
and then here what I saw you do is you
go off
and then on but you see that the tandem
Fields is always on
[Music]
so even if you let go
can you hear it
I reach for it
[Music]
you see how we're stuck
okay
[Music]
you feel attention
feel that the friction right okay
so to get the eye key
uh
aiki is the grace
you can't try for IQ
you release to
you release
and then ikey happens
if you try to stick
now if you try to throw now it's a
releasing okay
um
but it has real effects
do you see
hey
so again I'm I'm watching you and
there's a couple times where uh you're
here
and then he comes back whoa you see and
you your mind goes whoa you got you got
it and then now that's a self-state
that's the egoic response and so now the
adhesion just good the icy goes out
right and uh
As you move away from the eye key you
start to uh lose the tanden field and
then it just becomes external okay and
now we're just pushing them again and
now we can't do the my patrol because uh
I don't have the the energetic elements
to do the how to just uh deconstruction
do you see okay so you have to watch
uh for that okay if it's the tendency
what what I'm what I do is as I go I I
already going okay don't don't know
don't freak out don't freak out don't
freak out just keep the relationship
do you understand
uh
versus getting caught off guard and
habitually
going whoa okay me him right me might I
and and then you you and all that so
again uh the other thing I'd like to
demonstrate is tilting is not had a
deconstruction okay so in this drill if
he tells you still have to
make that Center go out
[Music]
you feel it
feel it
foreign
[Music]
not
pay attention you see it's there okay
and open your grip over here open your
grip do you feel it it was there close
your grip and now you don't feel it as
much if I open your grip and you feel it
you see this friction
thank you
it's strong right
it's not it's not a
tiny Force so you're doing a lot of good
cookie projection start working on that
technician